Rembrandt's
painting,
the Nightwatch,
perhaps the most famous work of his long
career and have the Dutch golden age
generally is not set at night and it's
not really a watch either.
It's a painting of the militia company
of district two under the command of
captain fronds Bennett,
coke,
which is also it's true law,
original name.
Essentially later after years of varnish
and low light dark in the canvas,
someone called it the night watch and it
stuck because,
well,
that's what it looked like.
In fact,
the nightwatch was meant to be a daytime
scene just like other portraits of the
Dutch civic guards,
groups of well to do Amsterdam.
Citizens tasked with keeping the peace
should threats come to the city walls
over the 16th and 17th centuries,
civic guard portraits became a genre all
its own and is painting in the
Netherlands,
moved away from spiritual subject matter
and toward the secular artists.
Welcomed commission work from these
wealthy guilds because they wanted large
group portraits again and again and
again.
But if you want to know why.
Rembrandt's is the only civic garde
painting that makes it into most school
curriculums.
Oh,
you have to do is look at it
commissioned to do what all the others
had done.
Show off the paying members of the
guild.
Rembrandt takes the genre and explodes
his vision through it.
The Night Watch is an eruption of
action,
shadow and light with drama that's more
suited to a biblical or historical epic.
Not 17 guys from peace time,
Amsterdam.
No offense to captain coke.
So what makes the nightwatch so great?
Well,
what hits me right away is the balance
that rembrandt strikes between chaos and
unity.
He clearly wanted to create a canvas
with a lot of movement,
but the challenge was how to make that
movement.
People lurching in different directions,
performing a variety of actions cohere
into a unified whole.
The keystone,
the part of the painting that holds
everything in place or the dual figures
of the captain and his lieutenant,
the rest of the portrait moves away from
them diagonally.
Indeed,
rembrandt places these lines directly
onto the painting in the form of weapons
and Poles,
and the effect isn't just two
dimensional and maybe the most striking
thing is the captain and the lieutenant
seemed to be emerging from the picture
plane,
the captain's hand ordering the company
forward.
It's as if you could grab it and pull
them out of the frame.
The lieutenants part is in the spirit
like weapon he's holding in.
His left hand is so expertly foreshorten
feels like it could cut you.
In fact,
based on the angle and the placement of
the weapon shadow on the ground,
the partisan is beyond the picture
plane,
or at least it should be.
Another trick rembrandt uses to achieve
this effect is one that will be familiar
to filmmakers.
The figures in the front are painted
with detail and clarity.
While the further back you go in the
composition,
the softer and hazier thing seemed to
get.
Rembrandt is mimicking depth of field
and optical phenomenon that can make
objects in focus pop from their
backgrounds.
All of these effects were carefully
planned by Rembrandt to anchor the
composition around the central figures.
The longer you look at the night watch,
the more meaning emerges from this burst
of frenetic energy.
For example,
the three men with guns are performing
the three main actions associated with
the archibus,
the primary weapon of this particular
guilt loading,
firing and blowing clear the gunpowder
pen.
In fact,
these poses match almost perfectly
engravings from a book called exercise
of arms,
a famous manual on how to use weaponry
released at the beginning of that
century.
This particular civic guard,
the Clo veneers is signaled again in the
chicken that's hanging from the young
girls waste.
A similar claw was on the Clo veneers
code of arms,
and while the captain's hand points
toward the viewer,
it shadow points toward his companies
function.
It's cradling the emblem of Amsterdam
Elian and three crosses.
The clo veneers were supposed to protect
the city.
The other notable feature is Rembrandt's
famous use of Couto,
sqirl and effective,
deeply contrasted light and shadow.
It's a technique that first came to
prominence in the work of Caravaggio who
used sharp contrasts and harsh lighting
to create intense drama in his
paintings.
The rembrandt was clearly interested in
this technique,
but for him,
light served a somewhat different
purpose and not only as remembrance
cattle softer than Caravaggio's,
but the light in his painting seems to
have a numinous quality as if once it
touches the subjects,
it becomes a part of them.
If we turn back to the nightwatch,
we can see that rembrandt uses
[inaudible] to single out two key
figures,
the lieutenant and the girl,
as we've already seen,
both these figures contained symbols
that call back to the group itself.
In the case of the lieutenant,
it's as if the captain's orders to
assemble are illuminating his second in
command and from his light.
The rest of the company is to fall in
line,
and yet compositionally the two light
had figures almost serve the opposite
purpose.
Instead of unifying the company,
the girl and the lieutenant seem
strategically placed to break up the
individual men in the canvas flanking
the captain.
They almost isolate him and thanks to
their contrast were drawn to the
haphazard actions and faces of each man
all seeming to be lost in their own
world.
The night watches capturing the moments
before the company sets out to its
collective purpose,
but the painting almost makes us doubt
that they'll ever get there.
Indeed,
by the time this painting was made in
16,
Forty two nearing the victorious of the
80 years war with the Spanish,
the Dutch were prosperous in civic
guards were more ceremonial than
necessary.
At a certain point,
these companies became clubs for men to
play with their weapons and chip in for
fancy group portraits.
It's not inconceivable that Rembrandt
may have been secretly making fun of
them a little bit in this his most
famous painting,
but that's the tension that the painter
captures in the night.
Watch and endless jockeying between
light and dark nation and individual
chaos and order.
Rembrandt could never let either one of
those elemental forces went out in his
composition because if he did,
he lose the most essential thing,
the thing he was striving for and
achieves within effect that makes this
one of the greatest paintings of all
time.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by Nord
Vpn.
If you care like I do a lot about your
privacy and security online,
you should absolutely be using a vpn or
virtual private network to keep your
data safe by allowing you to connect to
stuff remotely so that prying eyes can't
see your ip address and private
information.
I've had a few hacking scares myself
personally,
so vpns really helped ease my mind in
Nord.
VPN is your best option.
You're watching this right now.
You can get 66 percent off a two year
plan by visiting Nord Vpn Dot com slash
nerd writer or using the Promo Code nerd
writer at checkout.
I've shopped around in this space,
used a few vpns and nor vpn is
definitely my favorite.
Not only does it have military grade
encryption and 5,000
servers in 62 countries,
you can run it simultaneously.
Went up to six devices,
which means you can run it on computers
and phones,
so when you're on the Wifi at a cafe or
a restaurant,
you know you'll be saved.
This one's a no brainer and again,
Nord Vpn is offering my viewers 66
percent off a two year plan.
Just go to www dot nord,
vpn.com/nerd
writer or click the link in the
description to sign up and start
protecting yourself.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next.